what's the worst thing that's happened
to you today well I lost my luggage that
explains this shirt well I made my
reservation 11:00 a half months ago I
got cancelled last month and I only got
a place today for two nights
hey outside the house today State Farm
and team cocoa paired up to turn a few
lucky fans day around you big Conan
O'Brien fan yes can you do an impression
of Conan oh yeah totally
[Music]
yes I mean are you Conan O'Brien at this
I don't know I don't think I'm tall
enough what's the worst thing that's
happened to you today oh well like it's
always like the lines and everything
like that and like people cutting I mean
that's horrible right were you behind
anybody that was just like heinous I
mean sometimes people are smelly because
it's kind of hot it's kind of hot people
do kind of smell I realized that
throughout the day
you've been banking on something for 11
months and then it fell through today
yes but I'm here now it's okay you know
who else is here
State Farm is here to help life go right
oh thank you you gonna collect a lot of
those tiny little baby hat yes do you
feel like your day is about to turn
around um I'm hoping so I am I have one
more little gift for you
I have for you two tickets to a live
taping of Conan O'Brien tonight yeah
thank you State Farm for turning my day
around
[Music]
you gotta go left right yeah
that's feeling good I'm nailing this